dans le quartier branché de Botafogo à
Rio un petit drapeau du Québec et une
simple enseigne d'une école de français
le Québec recrute des travailleurs
étrangers qualifiés afin de combler sa
pénurie de main d'oeuvre et ils doivent
apprendre le français priorité absolue
le personnel de santé
les infirmières brésiliennes se
recherchent parce que leur formation est
solide comparable à celle du Québec et
je travaille dans l'emploi donc
[Musique]
pendant la pandémie les courses
donnaient en visioconférence c'est
devenu la norme
[Musique]
bonjour ça va
ça va bien tout le monde
oui ça va bien le propriétaire de
l'école et le journaliste Serge bois il
y enseignait autrefois sur ces 350
élèves au Brésil et dans quelques pays
voisins il a une trentaine de
travailleurs de la santé line la rivière
et la professeure elle se trouve à
Brossard près de Montréal
Amara est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer
pourquoi tu veux venir travailler et
habiter ici au Québec un arrêt est
fermement décidé à émigrer au Québec
elle a étudié la question avec des
infirmières déjà installées là bas
très bien des conditions de travail de
plus les conditions sociales
au Québec aussi il y a des sécurités
c'est une société plus égale
donc je crois que
les conditions de travail mais les
conditions sociaux aussi c'est c'est bon
pour vivre là-bas elle sait qu'elle a
encore pas mal de progrès à faire en
français les infirmières on les amène
jusqu'au niveau avancés parce qu'on a vu
avec l'expérience que une infirmière qui
a un niveau intermédiaire c'est pas
suffisant elle a vraiment besoin d'avoir
un niveau avancé parce qu'elle traite
des patientes des personnes âgées des
fois qui ont de la difficulté à
s'exprimer mais il n'y a pas que la
langue à travailler parce qu'à formation
en pratique l'infirmière au Brésil a
moins de responsabilité chaque
infirmière qui arrive ici en France
sédation va faire ce cours de
préparation là ou une infirmière
brésilienne travaille au Québec valeur
expliquer comment ça fonctionne comment
elles doivent être autonome quelles sont
leurs responsabilités et comment ils
doivent agir donc quand elle sorte d'ici
quand elle sort de l'école Québec quand
elle sorte de leur processus de
recrutement et elles arrivent au Québec
elles savent comment fonctionne le
système de santé ce qui fait
l'originalité des colles Québec c'est
qu'elle n'enseigne pas seulement le
français elle enseigne le Québec avec
ses manuels
alors ça par exemple vous voyez c'est le
1 c'est le niveau 1 et 2 de l'échelle
québécoise c'est vraiment très très
débutant déjà au quatrième cours on va
leur enseigner sont c'est quoi la carte
d'assurance maladie le permis de
conduire la carte de résident permanent
la carte d'assurance sociale comment on
fait par exemple pour aller chercher son
permis de conduire quand on arrive au
Québec vivre en ville pour un immigrant
qui arrive on s'est mis à leur place pas
question d'ignorer les expressions
pittoresques du parler québécois quand
j'ai acheté l'école en 2018 je me suis
dit il faut créer une méthode
entièrement québécoise où on se met dans
la peau d'un immigrant qui arrive au
Québec et qui connaît pas du tout la
société québécoise donc
objectif Québec c'est non seulement un
cours de francisation mais c'est un
cours de préparation à l'intégration au
marché du travail et à la société
chez nous quand ils arrivent au moins
ils comprennent ce qui se passe nous on
est capable de francisé en 10 mois
vous allez me dire comment réussites-tu
toi à faire quelque chose en 10 mois
qu'une alliance Française mais quatre
ans à faire mais ce programme là il a
été mis il a été créé
en se mettant en tête qu'on a besoin de
franciser des gens qui vont aller
occuper un poste au Québec il n'y a pas
que le secteur de la santé Québec
recrute des techniciens en informatique
en jeu vidéo des ouvriers spécialisés
également il y a des bourses d'études
pour le secteur de la santé mais pour
l'instant pas pour les autres un cours
de 10 mois coûte plus de 2000 dollars on
a eu plusieurs discussions avec des gens
du ministère de l'Immigration de ça fait
au moins cinq ans sinon plus qu'on se
parle mais on est encore bloqué quelque
part au ministère pour être
officiellement reconnu comme une école
qui travaille avec le gouvernement du
Québec qu'est-ce que ça donnerait à
l'école Québec si finalement le
ministère de l'Immigration nous
reconnaissait c'est que l'engin
actuellement qui est disponible pour la
francisation à l'extérieur du Québec qui
va presque exclusivement aux alliances
françaises pourraient aussi aller à
école Québec et là ça nous permettrait
de franciser beaucoup plus de personnes
comme par exemple des qui ont pas les
ressources financières pour étudier le
français école Québec a déjà franchisé
3500 personnes en 15 ans Jean-Michel
Leprince a du Canada rio janeiro